now you might think that Texas wouldn't
be a place where the diversity inclusion
mob would Thrive but courtesy of Chris
Ruffo we have bombshell reporting from
the University of Texas in Austin the
school's College of communication is
promoting the idea that objectivity
individualism and the written word were
all characteristics of white supremacy
culture and if you're white the school
wants you to atone for your power and
privilege same if you're straight by the
way at the Multicultural engagement
Center that sounds fun the school hosts
racially segregated student groups on
things called micro assaults and micro
invalidations that minorities endure a
constant barrage of but that's not all
kids here's the former assistant dean of
diversity and inclusion
an educator in a system of Oppression is
either a what
you're either a revolutionary
or an oppressor
which one will you identify as because
we already know that our institutions in
this country
are systems of Oppression that is by
Design so what will you choose to be
joining me now is Chris Ruffo a
Manhattan Institute senior fellow and
author of sit at City Journal Chris I
have to ask you right off the bat what
the heck is a micro invalidation I
thought I had heard it all but that's a
new one for me
yeah you know I'm not exactly sure maybe
it's if I don't sufficiently compliment
the shoes that you're wearing I mean uh
it's getting to the point of ridiculous
these are Phantom oppressions these are
fake oppressions but what's absolutely
real is that the University of Texas at
Austin is spending Untold millions of
dollars per year promoting critical race
Theory radical gender ideology and
training students explicitly for
left-wing partisan political activism
um this is a report that should shock
the conscience of all Texas voters and
certainly Texas legislators should say
why are taxpayers funding this kind of
ideological trash in our public
universities
well apparently they want you to use
um not boyfriend anymore but like babe
friend and date friend that you can't
say boyfriend or girlfriend anymore
that's another thing that apparently is
I think that will micro invalidate
someone somewhere Chris but you obtained
another video of that former UT
assistant Dei Dean she's a real winner
color blindness saying I don't see color
that means you're saying you don't see
the individuals who are in fact
identifying with their racial identity
color blindness is not good because it's
invalidating and it's also dishonest
that's it that I think we got it that's
what's in that's invalidating perhaps
but her role um I don't know where she
went on to but uh her role is taxpayer
funded correct
yeah that's right she actually moved on
on and up to Columbia University she was
doing such a stellar job apparently of
course
I mean
they've set up a perfect grift a perfect
scam they take millions of dollars from
all the hard-working waitresses and taxi
drivers and farmers in Texas uh they
take it and put it in the piggy bank for
critical race Theory and they have
publicly funded activism and they're
being very clear they hate the people of
Texas they hate the values of colorblind
equality treating people equally so
legislators have an opportunity there's
actually a bill going through the
legislature right now that would abolish
all of these DPI programs altogether
it's certainly something that needs to
happen oh Chris that that's fantastic
news let's hope it goes through thanks
so much hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else